- Les nouvelles encourageantes
sont rares depuis deux semaines,
mais celle-ci est digne de
mention : en Afrique du Sud,
là où la première vague mondiale
de cas d'Omicron a déferlé
il y a tout juste un mois,
la situation s'améliore
rapidement.
Dans l'ensemble du pays,
on observe une réduction
de plus de 40 % des cas
enenen l'espace d'à peine
une dizaine de jours.
Et dans la province de Gauteng,
la plus sévèrement touchée
par ce nouveau variant,
la diminution est encore
plus remarquable.
Plusieurs facteurs
pourraient expliquer
ce phénomène, dont le respectde.
Dr ANDRÉ VEILLETTE, immunologue
Institut de recherches cliniques
- Je pense qu'ils ont activé
des mesures sanitaires,
probablemefafafafaçon
très efficace. Et c'est comme
quand on ferme le robinet, alors
il n'y a plus d'eau qui coule.
- La population pourrait
égt t t t être mieux protégée
contre la COVID en général
qu'elle ne l'était durant
les vagues précédentes.
Si bien que le variant, même
èèèès contagieux, aurait moins
d'occasions pour se répandre.
- C'est clair qu'on a beaucoup
de gens qui sont... vaccinés.
C'est clair qu'en Afrique
du Sud, surtout, il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont
déjà été infectés, donc il y a
une protection qui est causée
par l'infection préalable.
- Il faut aussi signaler
que le nombre total
d'hospitalisations et de cas
sévères causés par Omicr
en Afrique du Sud est moins
élevé qu'on l'appréhendait
il y a un mois.
Une nouvelle étude
en provenance du Royaume-Uni
va dans le même sens :
le risque d'hospitalisation
serait jusqu'à 70 % moins élevé
avec le variant Omicron
qu'avec le variant Delta.
Évidemment, chaque pays
représente une situation
particulière, maisêêêêême,
beaucoup d'experts suivent
l'évolution de la vague
sud-africaine avec intérêt.
- Je pense quesisisisisisible
que l'augmentation très rapide
d'Omicron qu'on a vécue ici,
au Québec et au Canada,
va aussi être suiviepar une dimn
aussi très rapide.
C'est ce qu'il faut espérer.
- Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal